tandis que l'homme part à la conquête de
la lune tandis qu'il atterrit sur mars
par engin automatique très sophistiqué
interposés ce même homme semble
incapable de maîtriser l'inquiétant de
progression des maladies vénériennes
dans le monde en france et le chiffre
est effrayant un jeune sur quatre en est
atteint on est inquiet parce qu'il y à
une recrudescence étonnante depuis
quelques années et pratiquement dans
tous les pays quel que soit le régime
économique ou politique les pauses sont
multiples mais il y en a une essentielle
c'est l'ignorance ignorance totale en ce
qui concerne sa maladie quelques soit le
milieu social par exemple une notion
essentielle c'est la période
d'incubation c'est à dire le temps c'est
une notion de temps qui s'écoule entre
le moment du contact du rapport sexuel
qui a contaminé et le moment où apparaît
le premier signes cliniques etc des
périodes de temps de trois ou quatre
jours pour la gonococcie de trois
semaines quatre semaines pour la
syphilis et bien dès l'apparition des
premiers signes cliniques on doit
consulter trouvé de st immédiatement pas
d'auto très